crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab fish I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though or I exact the
soccer star JUCO above ground crew goes
better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnosis go download this week
last week here we go again for the crab
feast
I
i bestow a plan not the to suck our fees
for that ass oh that felt good that was
a while it was good and then you try to
get that second I thought that's what
that regard I was running out of the
glad hollering I guess I heard you ask
flat I think I got the bends on that
motherboard move we gotta work on
circular bring god damn good to see it's
good to be here sickle-cell FISA nation
great to be here with you as always Jay
Larson calm be calm is my website Jay
Larson comedy on all social media if
you're looking to find me or find shows
or find updates I'd like to say I didn't
really promote it as much on here as I'd
like to but the movie I shot a couple
years ago the invitation came out this
past weekend in some cities and some of
you guys I got one guy hit me up I'm
talking it had been on demand for four
minutes and he had seen it and so some
of you guys been really supportive it's
called the invitation currently as as we
speak it's in Austin it's in San
Francisco it's in Boston it's in Los
Angeles it's going to be any reared
itself by Southwest last year right yeah
so drafthouse films owns it it's in all
the drafthouse cinema's it's going to be
in New York it's going to be in st.
Louis it's gonna this Liz like 30 cities
so look into it the invitation it's a
really good psychological thriller some
really great actors in it Mikkel how
Schmidt who's on Game of Thrones Logan
marshall-green who's in prometheus John
Carroll Lynch who's in the movie Fargo
there's some really talented people the
director karen kusama is amazing the
writers are amazing i was very a lead
character in it yeah it's an ensemble
cast i was lucky to be in this move know
you are I know I walk down playing know
I did a great job no don't get me wrong
I'm very proud of what I did but I was
lucky to get in there you know I mean
they vary could easily been like this
what's he done no yeah but it's getting
great reviews and it's it's it's a
badass movie so it's also on netflix
right now yeah it's on broke top ten in
itunes so check that out it's called the
invitation is great on rotten tomatoes
and proud of you JLo Thank You sickle
cell I'm very proud of it as well the
23rd I'll be headlining the west side
comedy theater here in santa monica and
then uh in May the 20th i'll be at
zanies in nashville doing stand-up and
then in Bridgetown the second third and
fourth of May or June I'm sorry June
second third and fourth this live
podcast Ryan i'll be doing on the fourth
and then way way out 27th of july
through the 30th i'll be in dublin why
Ireland stop oh yeah show and then
London after that the 31st first second
third so any of those I'm coming across
the pond there you go ID please sickness
I want to hear about the features that
come out on the other side of the water
Ryan Sickler on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook Ryan Sickler com I'd like to
thank all the Feaster's that came out to
the comedy store last week so I couldn't
be there but that is one of us screen
for those of you that wanted to punch
him in the sold out sold out the belly
room up there with a I would arguably
have to say the best stand-up lineup on
planet earth on that night for five
dollars I would have to say his agree I
would have to say that's a tough
argument yeah so thank you all for
coming out the next show crappy stand-up
show at the comedy stores may third
Tuesday mate 3rd and the live crab feast
podcast we had scheduled yeah we had to
cancel that one on April nineteenth
there will be a May one will get those
dates and the links up for you as Jay
said bridgetown we're doing a live crab
feast podcast up their tickets for all
shows are on Ryan Sheckler calm and the
crab feast calm and as always like we
say thank you for ordering the merch
amazon links to premium apps the fan
pages all of that stuff and we're
excited excited to have a new sponsor
this week yeah excited to have these
guys on board because not only are they
going to be with us for a while but it's
a great product yeah this is a texture
thanks to pizza were all binge eating
thanks to netflix we're all
binge-watching but now with texture you
can start binge reading trust me it's
about to be a thing the texture app lets
you tap into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere using your
smartphone or tablet you can breeze to
hundreds of your favorite magazines
including back issues and that's what's
big
and pick the articles that interest you
to most texture texture has made it easy
to find articles you care about I don't
just get to read like you know anything
from Sports Illustrated or popular
mechanics or whatever men's health the
texture editorial and I say whatever
because there are hundreds of these
things the texture editorial team
recommends content for me every day plus
I could dive deeper with personalized
collections sign up for texture right
now and gain insider access to all the
content from the world's best
publication not just I mean also like
when you go read a magazine you'll get a
magazine if you put in to texture you
want to read about rory mcilroy things
will come up in Esquire magazine Golf
Digest like every magazine they have
that has something to do with them they
group it together for you and you can
watch live videos on there yeah it's not
like reading a magazine you know so much
extra content and here's the best part
texture is often astern a free trial
right now when you go to texture calm /
crab feast you'll gain immediate entry
to all the top magazines including back
issues and as Jay just said bonus video
content start binge reading for free
right now when you go to texture calm /
crab feast that's texture calm / crab
feast and I'm telling you it's I'm proud
to be often in that man yeah me too
because here's the other thing that
they're doing it that is really that Jay
Larson rate right there you can also
share the subscription with your entire
family alright so it's one subscription
I can't even say it subscription that
you can share with everybody integrate
let me come on and it's free right now
so they've got everything Sports
Illustrated Sports Illustrated kids
Forbes fortune girls like glamour
whatever men's health manager of popular
science already said that whatever pc
game in hair on it's on there and as far
as much you waste on magazines to have
this everyone has a tablet or an iPhone
I mean one name it you can get it on so
it's a great deal and I'm glad that we
have those guys because uh I think it's
a special offer yeah this is really
great uh also great this week are our
guests we're excited to have him on here
and yeah we have a really great guest
this week who you know he's got an
interesting life very very interesting
life and what I do want to say
is as you hear this episode this guy
went to bed at 12 and what well here's
old 12 years old I'm sorry yep not
twelve o'clock went to bed at 12 years
old and woke up the next born morning
with breasts female breath he grew
female breasts and what you're about to
hear all these crazy stories are a
direct basically we result later in the
podcast we get into the story of the
breast yeah but you need to know this we
want you to know that because we didn't
talk to about that story till later
right and all these other things you
hear up front or the rabbit hole he went
down as a result of dealing with breast
veamos well yes 28 and thinking there's
nothing he could ever do about it yes so
it's a it's a pretty amazing some
amazing tales to say the least so
without further ado let's welcome for
the first time to the crap fees please
welcome mr. Steve Randall say Randall
whoo thank you for having me guys oh
thank you for being here you come from a
good recommendation so Sam Tripoli yeah
he's been good to me man his exact words
where I put my name on it oh [ __ ] so
it's all new tripoli who I love Sam
Tripoli Tripoli man great I think he
loves to Tripoli he does third-person
yeah he loves the trip so we have quite
a bit to talk about with you but before
we get into that why don't you tell
everyone where they can find you some
media dates whatever you like great
twitter is at Steven Randolph to that's
at st e ven R a n D olph to same for
Instagram at Steven Randolph to add me
on facebook i'll add anybody and yeah
it's how to find me I laddie were you a
hey i'll add you though i always tell
people instant message me some weird
[ __ ] i say that on our podcast every
week oh yeah and i'm also the co-host of
the international bad boys podcast
monday's 3pm with sam Tripoli that's
international bad boys are all things
company at all things comedy yeah so why
the to whether to what Steven Rae ought
to the one was taken it's my dad shot
dad field he's a cameraman yeah you
wouldn't give it up here no real he's
I in the camera yeah you have a deal i
don't know it's my dad I mean you should
get big Steve Randolph yeah tell you dad
like yeah this should be you man yeah no
I know man it like his DC and people
take it the wrong way but don't tell him
what he today see what's that Randolph
what's up it has a camera we have a
camera he just retired like young a
tired Steve I off heavy won't even
[ __ ] give it up how often is he
Instagram I bet he's had a good shot
right yeah he did he did well he do all
he went he did entertainment he was a
you know worked his way up from the
loading room in the 60s 70s he did it
for about 40 years so your entertainment
family are you close yeah very close oh
man this is makes it even better that's
not close it's not close enough that he
give you up his interesting instagram
barely know how about your mom yeah
she's cool are they together still your
parents divorced divorced yeah um so I
mean we have a lot to talk about but
first I mean where are you from where
are you from where'd you start comedy
born or raised in pasadena i guess i
started comedy interning at Big Brother
magazine which was half skateboarding
half porn half comedy Larry behaves we
have three quarters one-third one-third
one-third it was a started bike what do
you call that would you say thirty three
percent yeah third 33.33 GT fresenius
skateboard guys actually a ten percent
skateboarding and eighty percent comedy
1080 okay I'm porn it was owned by Larry
Flynt actually he bought it by the time
I got there but it started by this guy
Sal Rocco a lot of guys like Knoxville
steve-o a lot of those guys were from
that magazine Sal Rocco yeah man who
sold the world i think is a good bass
player comedy no he started a
skateboarding comp like empire oh he was
like kind of like a larry flynt kind of
guy just crazy marketer dude and he had
this magazine which I read when I was 18
I got my hands on and it was all is
basically the pilot for jackass but his
way gnarlier those guys were just doing
[ __ ] that they were CKY and all that
before that was yeah those were the east
coast guys they sank up with this
magazine and then that's that became
jackass but I I watched one of these
videos and I realized I was going to get
into that
that company no matter what and so I
just started obsessively calling them
without getting into details this is
another story but we committed a felony
on somebody and filmed it looks like
yeah David okay and no date I finally
called them back and and we it my friend
in a ninja costume beat the crap out of
somebody I'm in broad daylight and I
called them the same number I'd called
30 times and gotten no call back and I
said hey we just jumped a rollerblader I
got it on film my friend was in a ninja
outfit we had live blades do instant
call back at my mom's landline like hey
what's up dude and I was this guy Chris
Naraka who writes for vice and and I
think he does a lot of stuff now but he
owns a skateboard company but he called
me and he was kind of a dick and he was
like huh two things I learned from high
school that speaking Spanish Spanish
class and typing I was i just used to
get stoned and there's this program
called typing tutor those two things
have gotten me further than all the
other i always wish i could type i see
people type my god damn it was a quick I
had typing 101 and hated it now I'm so
glad I had it it was great all the home
row man you a homer you just get stoned
and just played those typing games like
this little rocket ship typing tutor um
and so he goes how fast can you type and
I was like 30 words a minute and he's
like all right come into 8400 wilshire
and that was i was living in pasadena so
that was a hustler so I roll up I'm
[ __ ] nervous my friend had to drive
me some really bad direction the NATO
the ninjas cousin okay the ninjas cousin
did then it just cousins equally is
crazy um since then everybody's gotten
in so much trouble all these guys that
I'm like bringing up or like you know
got in big trouble but so he drives me
and I and I walk in and he was like
obviously your skateboarder I was like
nah and he the editor Dave Kearney he
started laughing and he was like all
right well he's you're obviously in the
comedy was like yeah he goes let's see
this [ __ ] video so i put in his VHS
videos brutal video and all these pro
skaters one guy he's in prison his name
is fabian Alomar his pro skater I think
he was from 18 street he was from some
gang I walk in and we're watching a
porno of him so he's a pro skater / porn
star / gangster this is Jesus everything
I've been a part of I grew up as an
entertainment family it's all you know
you get gets all but Big Brother the Big
Brother days were you know the porn in
the hustler and coke
it was really what you would think it
was kind of like a boogie nights on fire
in so walk in this guy who I'd seen in
all these skateboarding videos
everybody's watching everybody's all
sitting in these these couches that
Larry Flynt publications suite 220 and
I'm like all nervous and I walk in and
we're watching this dude this huge dick
just boning all these chicks on the
video and he's like that's me to look at
that and he was like he was like doing
commentary oh right like all this guy
wants to intern with us he's got some
video of him [ __ ] some person up uh
you know on rollerblades his friend and
like so it was VHS d so they took the
VHS porn out and then put it in it
everybody was quiet and I was like [ __ ]
this is really brutal and like it
desperate times calls I was like dude I
told my friend you [ __ ] this person up
so they did and so we I was it was
gnarly footage and so like the whole
room was quiet all these skaters like
dude that's bad vibe and so I just SAT
there in silence and I was like well
that's it and then the editor was like
oh he's like all right you're pretty
gnarly he's like all right you could
really type 30 words a minute I was like
yeah and then that guy private type 45
minute Google Dave Kearney his name's
Dave carnies a legend is one of my first
mentors David Dave Kearney big deal he
discovered Knoxville all this guy's so
Saudi Dave Kearney goes all right you're
the new intern and then just I mean I
fought Chuck Liddell on a 22 like he
beat the [ __ ] out of me like I just did
so much babe AZ to all this yeah there
what that I was there for like a year
year and a half and then wait hold on
how bad was it to be beat by Chuck
Liddell he didn't hold back did it no he
didn't hope he did the first round and
then they told him to take his leg out
and he would see this on youtube he I
was wearing a tutu and it was before he
blew up so he was on some video game but
no one knew who he was and he just
walked into the office and I was like
[ __ ] dude cuz Big Brother magazine was
this crazy magazine and they just they
would have nude girls all the time was
just mayhem you know and and he walked
in and I was like dude this guys [ __ ]
pretty intimidating and we went to the
this backyard the same backyard that
Knoxville did like all the first like
Jagger stuff and I walked back in that
backyard and he went easy on me because
I think he's kind of a cool dude you
know and this is before he was really
humble he's really nice like and this
was like before he got major fame no one
knew who he was I didn't know who he was
I wish he'd beat the [ __ ]
like this is for my Roble cousin Todd
job Gavin and he kicked my leg didn't
work for like a week and a half because
they're like take take his leg out and
so you can see in the video he kicked me
like three or four times real hard in
the leg my leg it didn't even hurt just
shivered and stopped working for like
three days my [ __ ] dude but I got in the
magazine and so like I just wanted to be
in the magazine so bad so I got a spread
in the magazine and I did I did a bunch
of really crazy stuff for that magazine
but during that time period I guess this
is a good start to the to the rest of
the stories because during that time
period I had gotten my wisdom teeth
pulled mm-hmm and I got vicodin I was
like [ __ ] this is awesome and taking
these with with some weed and and I
forgot about it i forgot about vicodin I
got it I knew I really liked it and then
you know um right when I got there Jack
asset jackass was just starting so I
went to dinner with Rick Kasich who's a
good friend of mine now who's like the
camera guy for jackass he's like oh
they're gonna do this jackass thing ever
he's gonna leave and it's gonna be this
big thing I was like I'll quit with even
big brother to do it to do jackass so
like half the guys left and he was like
it's gonna be this really big thing and
then sure enough it took often did it
and that everybody around around that
magazine they were just amisha seen like
how people were just given those dude
[ __ ] I mean it just it still happens but
it was just like crazy so these doctors
kind of came on just the party people
they like the typical Boogie Nights kind
of like party people came on and my
friend was like dude these doctors want
to be cool with us now is like doctors
like what the [ __ ] do we want with
doctors he's like you like do you like
vicodin or oxycontin I was like oh I
really like that and his doctor came and
just probably say it like it's like
picnics yeah I love love well I was 18 I
was you know I just was younger no con a
bein yeah yeah yeah these guys were all
like probably 25-30 and and so I i
started this guy just wrote his scripts
for for oxycontin Mike and Mike so I I
remember I got pulled over one time this
cop was like how the [ __ ] do you have
this but it was written to me so like I
never got in trouble and so I it got
really out of control me and this guy
Tyler got really really bad on on the on
the pills and then cocaine and it was
just it was just a really crazy time
period here so you're
addicted to oxy cocaine oxy and coke 18
Jesus in it and then working at Larry
Larry replications which is just a wild
building we were the only building are
we were one of the only magazines out of
like 30 or 40 that weren't porn so
there's a boating magazine video game
magazine and a skateboarding magazine
the rest were porn and so during this
whole jackass thing like we we were the
only ones the only ones in the whole
magazine that didn't have a dress code
believe it or not everybody kind of had
to dress nice because they're under so
much scrutiny is during the Bush
administration there but like they're
like we can't give these guys a dress
code so we would just be dressed like
[ __ ] fallin all over the place it was it
was one of the it was some of the most
fun I've ever had in my life man I was
just like people cuz you'd walk in the
building and you're in sandals and some
[ __ ] up shirt all [ __ ] up and I oh
he's with he there were those dude
you're like f they thought we were we
were gnarly you know they're like [ __ ]
they're like [ __ ] but we but so I during
that time period i started i started
getting into really weird [ __ ] and so I
was like what I'll just walk through the
halls like what do you do what do you do
and be like Lake World magazine or this
and saw I opened it up it was taboo
magazine and that was like the really
raunchy magazine like like like the tip
the the fetish magazine stuff and I was
like I was like what do you guys got
going on they had some like chick like
the other it was just like you knock on
these doors and always something we were
going on and so they're like oh man have
you ever been to a book oh I want to
have a daughter one day in a son and a
nice life and I just hope this isn't
stopping that it's already happened
you'd already know it's not gonna stop
okay yeah I want to coach a softball
team you know maybe in prison so this
girl go yeah this thing is this producer
girl she's like you ever been to a
[ __ ] and I was like what's a [ __ ]
and so she's like odds it's like chuck
liddell invited yeah yeah zion going I
was like you didn't know at the time
what I didn't know what it was oh yeah
that's that's gone through a lot of
firsts yeah 98 99 I known Foo cocky was
you know it's like all [ __ ] strong
how did she explain to you what exactly
that we're very blunt the
when people in the Ray J's I was like
like 70 or 80 dudes not on a girls face
and I was like call this number it's the
bukakke hotline he probably google is
probably still around but they're so
you're telling me this isn't just done
and porn there are what parties for this
it's a [ __ ] hotline it was this guy
jim powers ed powers or jim powers and
i'll tell you it was it was Jim pout
Jimmy you still got that you taught me
all I tell coach powers and said what up
I heard you guys do that the kid is but
I can't get in here I'll Glavine struck
Kevin dress in here oh so I call this
number this guy was really funny is like
welcome to the world-famous [ __ ]
hotline making porn stars all they can
be he's like guys it's gonna be in this
meat uh this the process it was it the
meat produce the produce section of
downtown LA it's gonna be in this meat
locker at this address and so you're
thinking it's just like it was funny it
was like are you [ __ ] kidding me
right like movie phone before the
[ __ ] it was like moviefone that's who
he was doing i never realized that's
what it was it was like moviefone that's
what he was doing that's what he was he
was spoofing and he was very funny and
while you're at a top round as three
money so so I pull up I pull up and I'm
in my car I'm in my car and I'm like
tripping out is this out of control uh
yeah I'm laughing but he's brother i'm
still like we're going to a [ __ ]
party i'm telling you this is the best
way to go to us I'm sure they'll never
gone away no it's over my [ __ ] days
are ok cos so i pull up in my car in in
it's literally like like this old
slaughterhouse in downtown LA and I'm
like [ __ ] I think it's here and there's
like a bunch of people in their cars
like people kind of walking around and
there's this guy that looked like he
could be like like a CEO or something
kind of like good-looking white dude but
he had like sunglasses on and a hat like
some kind of like disguise and was like
hey and he was like out hanging by his
cars like is this with the bukakke like
look around he's like yeah he like shush
his finger he's like yeah just be cool
you know like be cool dude don't ruin
the buca he's like yeah it's in there so
I so I roll in
and wait a minute so you now know what
it is why do I I looked on the internet
what it was before you're like [ __ ]
I'm in I'm like you I'm just you got
understand I'm come on coke I'm already
working at a porn mag you're easily
right I'm like dude you're looking to
see how far you can go how far in the
deep end you have a so far this year
down that rabbit this is yeah this so
this started going to meet at the
slaughter oh yeah sounds shady part
sometimes here now this was 20 years ago
yeah it's like yeah yeah [ __ ] how about
that 20 years ago though yeah yeah so so
I go in this time frame so your daughter
can put it all together when she listens
late I love you future daughter put it
on the hug you know it was all during
self-worth stuff and I'm working through
it in therapy right now baby girl um so
so I go in and there's about 30 dudes in
a waiting room and I'm like this is
weird it was like the front of this like
meat packing kind of weird place and
like that drains on the floors creepy
dude and I and I walk in and I was like
yeah I'm here to [ __ ] and so they're
like you have your your aids test your
aim test and I was like no and like we
didn't you can't participate I'm like
I'm just like listen I got it what I got
it what fixes them up yeah i'm just i'm
on heroin basically so i can't even get
involved anyways you know just I'm out
of this I'm just tripping out it's like
going to like a Vietnam photographer or
something and so like I go like okay
cool i was a guy work you know what the
hustler guys okay who do you know i said
these guys in there like cool cool so I
walk in and and the girl walks by me and
then she walks into the main room where
there's another 40 or 50 dudes in there
that were that were not checking in that
that had already checked in and so
there's probably bout 80 guys total and
so we walk in and and everybody just
starts jerking and they have music going
and there's Pete I'll never forget this
at everyone I went to there was dr.
pepper and pizza for everybody to have
and it was that was the creepiest part
civically Dr Pepper always dr. pepper
and always my friend went to wonder she
gave me a rodeo this area size arone and
there's always okay I used to work at
Trader Joe's and so did my buddy who
drove me to the first big brother the
uh you know the magazine and there's
always another thing there's always at
macaques a trader joe's bag somehow
someone had like a little trader joe's
bag with all those lotions in his little
like gloves and so my friend goes look
at the trader joe's bag at every [ __ ]
someone had a trader joe's back so now
we have an inside joke like when you say
every how many we talking here I want to
like eat or not I went to a reversible
doin comin ours yeah what do you think
either have the [ __ ] hotline and i'm
bored dude what's a reverse one it's
when the girls spray in a dude who's
jerking off so like 60 or 70 girls in
the backyard are all like that they're
squirters they all take turns yeah it's
good god I feel like a virgin set not
theory yeah but dude I'm trying to go
back in the light I just want to help
people and love the world dude um so
okay so I got back into the darkness
precisely just get this story out
alright so you get you're there and
you're there to watch so I'm there to
watch so I'm there to watch and so are
walks by you during this time period my
mom goes you need to quit that magazine
I'm living at home she's like if you
want to still live here you need to quit
that magazine get your life together so
like like two thousand two ish so I'm
there for like two years around this
time I'm I'm I I try to get off drugs
initially so I just go to like smoking
weed everyday doing like blow like maybe
once or twice a week I get off the
oxygen good way to get off that stuff
very proud of you helps but but so I got
my real estate license during this time
period ah I get a weird dude like that
like I miss all or nothing so my bucket
I just took my online test passed it
started doing industrial real estate
started selling a family friend this
would be a great place for [ __ ] look
at all these fetuses George is right
there so I so so then I started I
started selling warehouses and so I have
a suit and tie on I quit the magazine I
was always like heartbroken because I
wasn't doing comedy so here what
happened to [ __ ] we going back that
our guests that we're gonna go back to
that so my first one was like yeah oh
there's more pocket go cold turkey no
there's no ministers there's a lot more
[ __ ] so so during this time period
I'm not doing comedy anymore but I kept
my [ __ ] connection so I would do real
estate all day this is the whole
separate story but my dealer that
doctor stopped calling us back we ended
up with these dudes in Hollywood that
had these tanning salons and it was a
front for the same pills so one day my
friend and I 2003 I'm doing real estate
I was like to call you know call these
guys and they're like you were all out
of all out of the vicodin we have
injectable vicodin my friend was doing
steroids a lot so I got used to had seen
needles around so I was like at first I
was like trip and then and then he was
like yeah all you do is just I just you
know take this the solution it's like
the steroids you pull it out and put it
in and so I remember like my friend was
playing tiger woods golf and he just
pawed dude like he didn't even I knew
this guy's known this guy since we were
13 he pulled the hair the the the liquid
heroin basically pharmaceutical out
injected it in shot it up and started
playing tiger woods golf like and and I
look over at him like I'm like watching
him do this and that's his first time it
was the first time this first like he
just did it so like whatever he's a
gnarly do you think I who's like sold
acid in high school like he just like ah
dude my card dude you still an ass he's
like yeah it's good money like this guy
just had no like give a [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] so he's playing and I'll never
forget that he's playing tiger woods
golf and I'm like eight Billy he's like
what row his eyes are all [ __ ] up not
like how is it he's like it's the [ __ ]
I'm just went back to buy a tiger woods
call and so I'm sitting in this kitchen
in glendale at this nice house i'm like
[ __ ] here's my whole life and I just I
just injected it I was kind of like
looking at it looking at it and I just
was like oh that doesn't hurt and then I
just pushed it in I didn't do it
correctly but I pushed it in and boy all
my problems went away and I felt great
and so like whole new set of them and
then you delete the first thing we we
both said was why the [ __ ] we been
wasting that's everybody says once you
start injecting are you like what have I
been doing wasting this [ __ ] do you like
this is the it's like nine beers in you
like that so you're like what I've been
wasting time with beers and you know and
eating the pills like that and so then
that started that but i'm still doing
real estate i'm actually selling these
[ __ ] buildings i'm doing really well
because i'm selling rock quarries uh
slaughter houses churches out the valley
22 Persians Israelis Russians the
hardest market but i'm i'm on coke and
now shooting liquid heroin I don't care
so like I would slick
my my hair I would I would dress nice
and I just didn't give a [ __ ] and so
they've like bro I don't know about
these price I'm like yes and I was just
like gnarly cuz I didn't I wasn't scared
of hearing the word know so i was just
so aggressive and I didn't care that I
just you know it's just like I just
started selling building so I so I did
pretty well but I would go to these
[ __ ] zat knight and just take my
friends that back did you want to trip
out and go to [ __ ] so so it's a good
story yeah i mean i'm i'm in again
hundreds i okay i never heard anything
like you guys look at me crazy so I'm
boy you're crazy you're great you're
liquid heroin okay I can friends the
[ __ ] box so then so then I asked a
friend so I like didn't want to do
something comedy related so I ask a
buddy that he had this moment at the
[ __ ] party around that time I'm like
this needs to be this needs to be
captured also during this time you know
I'm Boogie Nights how the guy would they
went to that one dudes house where he's
lighting the fire road that I don't know
what it is about like hard drugs I i had
a jujitsu outfit that I just started
wearing at night so off would come the
suit and tie and I would just start
wearing this jujitsu outfit were all
he's a gay again around was rolling
around with sunglasses who these these
low class i got from am PM and a geat
that was because I thought I was johnny
cage for mortal kombat like i was
obsessed with that I thought I was him I
was like dude this is the real me I was
living at my dad's house my dad was
trippin i was gonna say when your
parents say like i was working at the
studios they were divorced my dad was
working studios 18 hours a day but Hugh
come home I'd be like [ __ ] Johnny Cage
and there you just trippin dude and so I
you think you deserve Stephen Randolph
to what I'm actually says in that notice
yet Bob making my amends and it also
program to him this week i just finished
you know writing it so I you know I'm
trying to make all this right seven
eight years later but uh eight years
over later was ten years ago so yeah
yeah I've judged i'm i'm on a different
path but so so I I met this guy that was
a really funny dude he filmed funny
videos and I was like hey you wanna go
make a funny video aradia at all times
there were you go were you like rolling
in money cure no no I this isn't any any
heroin addict and any junkie will all
second this you can get a
five-thousand-dollar check that shit's
gone you know you're just gonna spend
and it's not just a just stupid [ __ ]
you're just so [ __ ]
it looks good if it lets do whatever I'm
you're always at zero so I'm on a
junkyard off this guy to karate suit
yeah like it was a weird it was a weird
weird weird weird life weird like how
are you at this point now I'm probably
24 at this time 24 so I'm doing this
[ __ ] i'm selling real estate during the
day and bail i'm doing enough to get
well during the day selling these like
airplane hangars it was just like you
know i would i be walking around the
Burbank Airport you seen these hang or
just [ __ ] putting them in just like
well I want to write a book about that
because the [ __ ] I had some a lot of
weird moments doesn't do service to this
story but yeah so there's there's a lot
of space there for some weirdness that
that definitely went down and so I asked
this guy said hey do you wanna in
there's video of this I'll send any
listener and i'll send you guys it's
very funny and so there's a there's
footage of so i asked the guy said I
said well you come in and shoot a comedy
spoof video at [ __ ] and this dude was
weird enough to be like you that's an
art piece that's some [ __ ]
tripped-out [ __ ] he's like calm down he
was like this really creative director
photographer guy and I said all
interview these guys who were jerking
off on the girl and he's like you know
what I was like I have an editor so my
one of my best friends Casey maloney
from growing ups great editor just a
weird dude also on heroin at the time
and cocaine and you know we were just
we're just doing weird [ __ ] and so and
so he goes all right let's rock and roll
so we roll to the [ __ ] with a camera
crew and the guy it's not ed powders two
powers is why don't you know google it
was called american [ __ ] it uh uh
nowadays you just google anything so so
we roll up with the crew and he goes
it's all in film he goes what do you
guys do it and I'm like this is my crew
we want to do a little fun video he goes
yeah like I at like a Ramones shirt on
or some kind of punk rock so you can
tell the punk rock part of me is like
all right just don't get too involved
cool so I'm gonna karate outfit with the
film crew and I'm interviewing dudes
about the Iraq war who was jerking off
on his girl and there's like a ba all
it's given a real questions there's
eight dudes beaten off on a couch I'm
like you let me just sit with you guys
what do you think about what's going on
because even though is that jacked up I
still have kind of some comic timing and
so you probably the best time in your
life I didn't care I wasn't scared so
anything your heart was like do you're
like yes you know I just said yes that
you know to whatever my instincts were
at that time and there's no that's what
about
and sober I second guys everything like
hey guys is good story the back then I
like this is great so so we film this
video I remember doing it I have all the
footage I go to Mike but my friend Casey
knows like I got some footage man see if
you could do anything with it he calls
me back the next day and he goes dude I
nailed it and I go he talked about he
goes you know Madonna's justify my love
and I go yeah he goes I [ __ ] set the
whole thing to justify my love man he
goes it's [ __ ] perfect and I'm like I
go to his house and dude on you don't
laugh when you're on heroin we do we
laughed we're like this is [ __ ]
strange dude and it's just really well
edited it's got a complete story and
it's weird and so it's me and every
knees guys in the karate outfit they're
getting pissed there's guy shoving me
while the broken off like like this one
black kid who looked like Chris Rock was
like may get off me get off me i'm like
know about the war you know i was like
just I was like all all engines leave
they let you in that no with a camera
yeah it was wild roll up on the dude
from the car earlier with the hat in the
sunglasses Jesus Christ but I say he was
in the video he was no videos out there
so so it was like it was this really
this Ramona done jerking on I grabbed
you to sign a release please make we did
I I asked a few guys but I was like ow
whatever so so it was a really
right-handed it use your left hand right
here one touch everything with a end up
hugging the girls but it was very
graphic so the girl at this point has
had 70 loads on oh I'm talking to her
I'm hanging out and she's just glazed
it's it's if we're guys we've all seen a
lot of porn for me to say this its
graphic dude yeah it's uh it's like whoa
dude it's like Vietnam photography
that's what icon was in that that phase
of like this is this is so far off the
edge I can't believe this like we got a
document this and it ended up kind of
being funny in a [ __ ] up way maybe in
a couple years I won't think it's funny
I still I watched it recently I still
well what you did to them i think is
yeah yeah asking them serious questions
about the Iraq war while they're in this
[ __ ] yeah ik its I can't believe they
let you in there said that so I have
this video this DVD I put it away I
don't think anything of it I'm doing
real estate I have a breakdown the real
real estate agency goes we have this new
program it's called data quick you could
just type in anybody's address and it'll
tell what you with the paid for the
house all there
nation you know obviously have ethics I
took all these classes on ethics and my
you know you don't don't abuse this and
this is for you know perspective buyers
that you know and have relationship with
blah blah there were there really cool
real estate agency it was me that was
the problem but no one ever got wouldn't
I never did anything wrong i was i was
actually good pretty added integrity
when i was selling it was just there's
just numbers but so i start typing in
michael jackson i start typing in for
all these people's information are
coming up it just tax information so
it's no there's no hide nothing so i
type in um i type in Bob Odenkirk I was
a huge mr. show fan you guys fans a
missile show I never watched I never was
introduced as a kid that that was my
thing you know how we all have dancers
like so many dudes yeah it was the
Farley era Phil Hartman of Saturday life
but the last time I remember really
laughing was that was that's my there my
Monty Python you know and so it was like
you know jack black's or Silverman
everybody mary lynn they all came from
mr. show and that was like that was one
of those things when i saw Big Brother I
saw that for the first time I was had
such a depression and I'll get into the
tits later I had breasts at male breast
but that's a I don't I don't know how to
I don't how to weave all these there's
so much dude you just drop that on
everyone alright so that's another
that's another plus let's talk about Bob
Odenkirk look then we'll talk about your
titties sure sure so so during this time
period i'm also fighting on mexican
television that's a different story but
i'm out of my mind at night so that's
when i'm really like holding it down
during the day and then just bang Oh at
night just getting weird and what you're
doing drugs during the day to a nut
maintenance enough enough to not get
sick to get you to nut to the night to
get me to the night brother and so so I
look up Bablu he's there I'm a huge fan
I did a couple bumps in the bathroom I
wrote this [ __ ] letter I still think
it's pretty good Bob dear Bob I'm
working in real estate I'm so unhappy
all I've ever wanted to do was being
comedy I'm so scared by what do i do I
don't know where else to do lick the
envelope [ __ ] and send it to Bob
Odenkirk home or his wife and children
you know is home you don't do that to
people you don't know didn't know that
yeah that's scary like two weeks goes by
my mom I didn't hang out with many
people that but everyone's my mom made
by I don't I won't judge oh my heart
breaks you've been hearing this but hmm
not funny but but oh I don't know why
this is bothering me but everyone
thought my mom would would like would
like be like I won't just let's hang out
you know huh I'm beating like emotional
i know that's okay yeah yeah so we're
excited always power through this would
caught with with comedy and being like
emotionally distant laughable a lot of
weight she would ask to hang out because
she was concerned or cut spending any
time with son was dying and you know
every everybody knew it I had enough of
a mouth on me to play it off during the
day but anybody who really knew me like
you know I don't care who you are did
you just [ __ ] takes in here but so my
mom was like dude you want to watch
march of the penguins with me great
movie great movie so I'm like cool so I
go and watch march of the penguins hold
on let me do a couple o it the whole
time you know it all time shooting up in
my car you know that the whole just it's
just it's gnarly dude it's a different
your zombie and I gotta remember that
that that's that's what you know I was
spared for that because the 12 steps but
so I leave morgan freeman i think was
nary you know it was cool movie so i
will i walk out of the movie theater i
get a call myself from like some random
310 number i just bobble in a clerk's
office I was like oh you know cuz you're
always when you're on blow you're always
like due to the boss news about the
heaven oh I would go I'll go I always
say [ __ ] like a cokehead junkie dream is
like the mmm like you'll see you know
like I'm gonna prove you wrong we'll buy
you a mansion mom mom I always guy I
just want you to be well like I like I'm
gonna buy you a Ferrari shut your ass up
and so I was like I as as soon as they
said that I was like haha you [ __ ]
are going to see I've made it now and
like Bob Odenkirk surface we got your
letter and Bob we're gonna patch Bob in
right now and I was like so purse Bob
Odenkirk me is so professional you know
he discovered Jack Black all these
people I'm like finally he's discovered
me you know and they're like we're gonna
patch pet this is this is really out
happen this you guys are gonna patch Bob
through so i just just seen march the
Penguins and what my mom I told my mom
gave me a minute i'm at romans in
pasadena bob odenkirk people and he goes
[ __ ] are you dude they just slid alike
and I'm like oh my of anybody I don't
care if I piss off Axl Rose I'm like you
bummed out Bob Odenkirk like that's like
not cool you know he's the coolest like
it'd be like bumming out Jerry Garcia
like do I don't care if you're into that
[ __ ] or not dude like bummer you know
what I'm like my heart spokeo's who the
[ __ ] are you I'm like oh my real estate
she goes isn't that illegal you found
title and I and I said a job I was like
yeah you got a great great deal on your
loan and he did nothing yeah yeah yeah
I'll give you yeah I thought every do
what else you get it you're glad you're
gonna go am I costly on the way down
yeah yeah nothing there he gives me
nothing [ __ ] are you don't do this you
know he's like I have a family and he's
like it did you he's a good dude you
know he's like a good family dude he's
like you know [ __ ] do this trip and
trip and tripping and I'm just like oh
my I've never cared about authority I'd
never give it but site did you bum out
Bob Odenkirk you're a dick dude oh my
god damn so I just took it took it took
it and so I'm just like listening dude
to him go for like he's just trying to
find out who the [ __ ] this psycho is
singles what do you want I'm like dude I
just need your advice and then he was
like you know not to do this ever again
i was like no he goes cindy or whoever
you still on the line is she's like I'm
right here Bob record again yeah yeah
right right here brother alright here's
my police but yeah yeah and my moms like
what is it like my you know my favorite
you're still your mom's it over there
just checking out books at this you know
bookstore do you want a salad yeah it's
over you know and so so she goes pencil
something in with Stephen a month from
now Wow and we'll go to we'll go have
lunch with them and she goes okay he
goes all right I'm out of here she goes
okay Stephen so I need your information
all this stuff and I'm still thinking
I'm gonna get arrested when I go and
she's like so in a month from now call
in to our office and we'll have a date
for you and so I just sent the piece at
the timer month from now month goes by
I'm telling a couple my friend time huh
yeah I Bob Odenkirk upset my phone you
know thing or whatever Mike my father so
you know I'm like what is this you know
we all try to figure out what
this beast I call it a month same girl
Sydney's like oh hey Steven how are you
okay yeah i remember that lunch let me
hold on just please hold bob says to
call back in another month and so I said
okay well I am a psycho and I will play
this you know what i mean so it's like
all right this is where it's at i'll
play this game like that's what i did
with big brother i called them 30 times
that's why I have no I have no patience
for people who don't like push hard
because like I called 30 times again in
the Big Brother do you know beat a man
up I I work at the dude I'm 35 I worked
the door at the comedy store I plunge
[ __ ] toilets I clean up nasty [ __ ]
for five minutes stage time like however
crazy I am I have work ethic always have
in like like I work hard dude I work
hard for opportunities and so listen no
one heard of a guy doing 30 words a
minute that didn't work hard at
something to be proud yeah so whoo so so
so I think they're giving me the
runaround so finally I called I call by
that that next month and she goes okay
mr. Odenkirk wants to meet you at this
place called the pig on labrea next
wednesday at noon like oh my god it's no
longer there so it's only the barbecue
joint yeah yeah I was like he's been
orale Melrose I think yeah right around
right round melroy exactly where it was
you never forget never forget that so
I'm so I go good choice Bob Odenkirk he
knows the deal you know so I roll up and
he rolls up with this huge like 800 page
civil war book and I'm just like this my
idol so he rolls up with his huge novel
and I'd been there for like 45 minutes
before like going over I'm gonna say I'm
gonna suit and tie and you know just cut
off from doing real estate I like fake
like I had a thing you know of an
appointment went met him he was just
looking at me up and down and I was like
you can I buy you dinner lunch like no
no no that's cool i'll buy it so we ate
just kind of like in silence and he's
like okay so I was like yeah he and he's
like he's just a real like he's dude
he's a genius you know just like looking
at me and I'm like feeling I'm looking
at me I'm eating like I couldn't even
eat dude he's like why don't you eat I'm
like I can't you you're making me
nervous and that I think he was kind of
like laughing at that cuz I was like but
I can't eat right now like he was just
eaten and I was like I I love food but I
was like I was like I can't eat you're
making me nervous he's like all right
he's like so what's the deal so then I
realize you
had [ __ ] I told him about the Big
Brother thing that became jackass and he
said them they're actually really [ __ ]
with me and I don't believe in anymore
because I don't expect to be a part of
anything that big again and I was like
oh that was my worst nightmare like that
i missed the boat with that I'm you know
I'm never gonna be a part of anything
cool and so like when he said that like
my walls just cool you know closed in
and then no there he goes and says that
but he's not one of the you know ten
years later would be on one of the
biggest shows and you know the world and
you know call salt so you know that's I
still have hope that I'll be a part of
something cool um so he so we end up
talking for like 2-3 hours we end up
getting getting along really well and he
was like all right all right he's like
just call me tell me where your tell me
where you're gonna be what your deal is
she goes a good guy he's a good guy he
goes he goes uh you hanging out at UCB
theatre so this is 2005 be honest I had
I had heard a story about on Kirk about
a guy that was like peeping through his
windows and pulled a knife on him you
mean serious he gave the guy development
deal hahaha so he ended up talking he
goes you need to go you need to go to
UCB keep in mind i'm on heroin during
this time so he goes he goes you need to
go to UCB and start hanging out there
and I was like alright cool I was like
cool in so i go back i go back to uh to
my real estate office I'm like and he
goes and you're doing real estate in
your mid-20s he's like I because i was
working at ed bewick stunning food when
my first job of it was my first when my
first joke was on God on Dennis Miller
told my first joke on SNL and he goes he
goes I you're already have a career he
goes that's out it you gotta be out of
your mind and so you know Bob Odenkirk
tells you that so I walk back in the
next day I go I quit and they're like
you [ __ ] quick so I was doing really
well cuz selling like [ __ ] crowd
wasn't sleeping I was selling like you
quit I'm like I'm gonna be a world
famous comic and they're like oh my god
you quit I quit I started working at
home restaurant on Vermont Inn in a most
fearless instantly the next day got a
job at home restaurant people my family
was like you're quitting real estate cuz
they they were like that was the last
bit of normality that I had and so
they're like you're quitting you're
quitting real estate so so I start
hanging out at UCB I might kind of
snooping around and they have a night
called [ __ ] up an illegal
videos and so I got sick cities yeah I
was like well I gotta get something in
that and then I go I saw Matt Besser cuz
that's the guy who runs it but no he was
actually hanging out in 2005 but it
wasn't that full all the time so I go up
to him and I'm like hey I got a
fucked-up video and he goes great you
could show it at or night it's his
brand-new night we're having and
everybody's gonna be there it's a great
opportunity for you so I roll up in the
karate outfit course I did so much
heroin so much cocaine I'm out of my
[ __ ] mind and I've got a DVD and I'm
like this is all I need to do is just
show people this and I I go and I sit in
the back there's 200 people there the
theaters packed it's going crazy this
ratio sands there's just all kinds of
like famous people all the UCB guys are
there is this big night and everybody's
putting in these [ __ ] videos then
like taking a [ __ ] on this or light to
Barbie doll's head on fire like we have
this guy named Steve and obviously in am
I here and they always in a karate suit
and they go he's got the craziest video
here and you know we just know and so
they're showing it on a projector on
there you see be in surround sound 200
people lights out you really get
attention it's not on some iphone like
you're strapped in [ __ ] for six
minutes of the worst thing you've ever
seen so they go okay give give to the
sound guy Steve this better be good you
you popped off about it so Madonna it
starts off with Madonna's justify your
love wanting cheeky and it goes welcome
to [ __ ] and just in it started and
and I could just see everybody god oh my
god the guy Jerry minor who's on mr.
shows up on the stage with me he looks
at me he goes oh my and I go I whispered
to his yrics I'm like a crazy person and
I was like clearly I was like this is
ruining my career he goes what career
man i go i don't have one he goes who
gives a [ __ ] and so so the lights go
down f 200 people are forced to watch
the gnarliest [ __ ] footage of all
time edited the madonna me helpmann like
hugging the girl covered in [ __ ]
craziness the lights go on two girls are
crying hysterically people people are
throwing [ __ ] at me dude in like booing
and throwing [ __ ] at me and I'm like I'm
like sorry I thought this was called
[ __ ] up in illegal videos
I'm so sorry I thought this was UCB and
Matt best goes let him stay and so he
goes he goes come up on the stage and
they did a panel waste on coming yes sir
let you stay he let me stay and he goes
because you think this is art I go for
me art art gets a reaction out of people
it gets a dialogue going and they go
this is an art and the girls were going
he's a woman hater and I go no I'm not I
just this is just something I did I go
this is art look at we're all talking
about my video all the other videos no
one's talking about and like do two
girls were crying cuz i guess they did I
feel I do feel bad for this I do feel
bad for this there are two interns that
just start at UCB they brought their
families that night and so they're all
forced to watch hockey together it'll
don't go those two separate set the
rules were weeping crying and and people
were throwing [ __ ] at me up there on
stage throwing [ __ ] me and I had to get
assured out of the thing and I wanted to
start taking classes there they would
not respond to me but then after like
six months like I got it and I really i
graduated from UCB as i did their whole
course so that's my that's my UCB bob
odenkirk [ __ ] story and i actually
wrote him a year ago and he wrote me
this really nice letter because i
remember you you goes you know I can't
help that he goes I used to love helping
people I can't do that as much anymore
with call Saul and all the stuff that's
been happening my own life and I'm now
focusing on my own career and all this
stuff oh god bless you and you know good
luck to you and all this [ __ ] he's not
afford me that [ __ ] video yeah I
haven't got you no I meant him oh yeah
you know he I don't think he knew that I
did that so you also said you had
breasts you just drop that in there I
didn't forget it what what is that all
but only told this twice well I'm take a
sip of water a plea told it anywhere
twice hold it on stage twice and it
kills and I and I told it on the podcast
once and I just it's just heavy so I'm
as if the other one was like you know
we're on heroin yeah but this is
personal this is embarrassing to me all
the other stuff is I'm doing this crazy
stuff but this is something that I've I
felt very do you feel comfortable
telling it the idea I got I got to you
don't even if you're not telling this
stuff for me as a comedian as a
storyteller if you're not telling the
stuff that makes you cringe then you're
just bullshitting yourself so this this
is good for me it's good it's good so I
me and if you
out there listening because everybody
has every time I tell the story which is
three or four times every time I've told
this story I people come up to me and
said I have a surgery on my nose a
surgery you know so if you're out there
and there's something on your body you
don't like it can be fixed it can be
fixed and it's changed my life um you
think we'll get your nose done with that
anything will get your nose done again
the doctor when I went in the doctor
asked me if I was wanted to get my nose
job here for my tits sir wait that's a
whole different that the assistant said
that and I was like no to have a big
nose no no well okay come on I won't
hear what these deaths okay so when I
went through let me just say this when I
went through puberty I got tits the
summer before going to an all-boys
competitive sports high school I went
through puberty my nipples got like
sensitive and hard and these little
rocks under them and then all sudden one
day I just got hit one day like you
wanted [ __ ] day come on I went to bed
with a man's chest and woke up with
breasts yeah like that's how old 12
puberty 11-12 what sighs what sighs me
wrong and go for were you like if like a
chick with a tits yeah like if you were
to lift up you like all that chicks got
some a's we could work with that all
come on those you know enemy oh that's I
don't know it's really a good start
there with I'm just trying to deflect
with humor so so [ __ ] uncomfortable
okay I hope this is good it's not your
choice you know I mean it just you
nature yep they did it did so so I went
in for for freshman football right
before when they do the cough but yeah
I'll do it this [ __ ] [ __ ] man this
doctor could you know could have changed
my life if I would have got this you
know it is what it is I wouldn't have
all these great stories but in it fueled
the craziness everybody's running from
something that's crazy so you know I
went to her and she did that the test
under my balls cough and they go hey Doc
you know I got tits and she looked at
him and I go what can I do I'm going in
this [ __ ] vulture his snake den of us
who is traffic high school shirts and
skins like you know and she's like oh
nothing you could do put down my shirt
and walk down there free chunky no
that's that that's the thing I've been
I've been off and on chunky my life but
no when I I've had a V in my stomach
before you know and and saw the Ted
that's how you know it they didn't go
away you know wasn't yeah so that's it
how long did you have up from from
twelve to twenty eight wow I'm the most
important is my dude net have bad
posture because of its oh so it's called
even Google is called a gynecomastia got
it happens in a person either it's
puberty or pot those are the two things
I cause of my mom actually works for a
plastic surgeon now they get guys all
the time will come and just get it you
know sucked out and stuff like that um
but mine was them from puberty ask the
doctor later so so we'd you said or we'd
a lot of pot create causes tits you know
um so I so I go into an all-boys very
competitive school over here st. Francis
and you know and uh [ __ ] man like took
off my shirt a couple times so I just
got real snappy with comedy real aware
if people were looking down there and
real ready to react with violence or
with jokes it was like oh I can't kick
this guy's ass then I'll just joke and
walk away if I kick this guy's as I'll
make sure that they never says that
number one I used to love the beach
can't go the beach now can't cope you
know it's just it was it was a [ __ ]
for someone who like was pretty out
there and pretty wild and like the beach
and like you know eight were you like
crazy into drugs and all that stuff no
not yet oh so now I think this had to
have had so we did nothing to do it no I
didn't even smoked weed yet I'm not
talking wheat I'm saying nothing having
an insecurity like this and pushing you
to a place where like who's going to
accept accept me it was nice clearly
that magazine full of [ __ ]
Psychopaths was a place for you to feel
that you could be accepted yeah and I
escaped that without them without them
seen it that want the one time for for
prank I took off my shirt and this guy
goes I'll never forget this is this guy
it was very nice and this guy goes you
have to and he stopped and I like gave
him the look of like you could end me
cuz it's from in a magazine they got a
hundred thousand circular it would have
been you know that would have bent it
boy or something you know but and he he
just looked at me and I I i can get
emotional thing I never I never really
think about that but this guy did he
just you know what I mean he had no he
had me and was like nope and didn't say
anything well you know I was like it was
like that that Wonder Years where Kevin
saw that his PE teacher was saying the
claws and he figured it out and he
didn't decide I don't know I'm thought
about that in 20 years but yeah whatever
see what happens on the crappy yeah I
haven't thought about that they got the
guy the guy looked at I mean it would
have been an it would have been a
colossal nightmare at that level you
know not I think that's what kept me
from that's what kept me from exposing
myself as comedian before I had the
surgery I didn't do you know so I was
always afraid that you know you're up
there explosions up some ago oh yeah
you're funny but you got tits and I saw
that happen to a guy late oh my heart
broke and I was a guy I didn't like
doing stand-up he had the same thing and
I saw someone do my worst nightmare to
him since i've had that i was like oh
god but so wait how did you hide them
did you disbanded a man would enjoy you
to try where's van loads was bandaged
ace bandage always a virus yeah and
they're like I just think you know my
therapist said like when I first went to
him and that that came up he was like
your parents were asleep they're great
parents but he was like you know and so
I'm very aware of that [ __ ] now if I
ever have a kid who has like a weird
something that's it's getting cut off
immediately dude so so um what I would
do is I would wear like flannels with
pockets and I would wear it you know
there's certain shirts and there's
certain this and there's certain that
night just convinced everybody all the
beach sucks we're not going to beach
that's lame you know what I I did
everything in my power and my sales
power and guys that's right you're
selling real you're doing all that door
in these years gorgeous evolved this 28
he was horrible but during high school
it was just it was just like it was just
a nightmare nightmare nightmare every
time I took a shower just be like you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I hey man yeah it
was it was a nightmare but I was a funny
guy I I got you know attractive girls I
would always have but I I never took off
you know I'd [ __ ] with a shirt on it was
it was it dude I'm telling you it was a
night [ __ ] mayor so I end up after
all after all the [ __ ] stuff the blah
blah I I finally I'm like I'm on heroin
my dad finds a spoon he's like you got
you got to go to rehab you're out of
here you got to go to rehab so I go to
this rehab and this ladies like slaves
like smart people in rehab they know
what the [ __ ] you know now i know from
being sober if someone's on the you know
everybody's running from something
that's that [ __ ] up you know they're
not looking at two or three secret
that's how I'm able to help people now
I'm like do what you know what's the
deal I've tits and people just kind of
you know you throw that hand down and be
like I have this I that people listen
right now I guarantee is there driving
like this is going to be the one story
that's gonna help somebody like you know
this is the not cool story but like I
know someone who's listening to this
right now
knows exactly what I'm talking about so
um yes in my book this is the cool story
oh thank you man yeah yeah it does it
feel it feels really embarrassing and
I'm i think it's I'm like I'm I'm
thankful that you're sharing with us
yeah 3 guys make me feel safe that's
cool like you know we're all older and
it's just cool but I mean I can't my
posture started yeah it was in and I
would have to act like i was crazy so I
beat their beg you were in a jacket I
grew up in Southern California it's
summer I beg to Donna it's not hot to me
you know what I mean I was like oh god
16 years you went through this i
remember i i i i was working at a
restaurant this kid had like really big
ears and I watched him every called him
Dumbo and picked on him he was one of
the Busboys just Mexican kid working
there probably illegally and you know
underage and and then he I saw him
slowly turned into a gangster and I was
like it was [ __ ] years man cuz he
would he was a shy nice sweet kid you're
like fitted what's up Dumbo and then he
started getting me the big dumb both
isn't that then he was a [ __ ] you know
and i'm like you're calling him Dumbo
every day and then he slowly started his
socks would come up he started getting
hard and you know that I don't he's on
his path but I mean [ __ ] cut those
ears you know cheese school districts
but so I mean especially living in
pasadena and and Los Angeles with all
the plastic surgery craze and everything
why didn't didn't you ever think of it
yourself like when you get the 16 your
ass or so terrifying it wasn't like
having a weird nose or it was so I just
I just left my soul left my body and my
soul left my body and it was like you
know teachers they be up what's wrong
with you you know I'm a decent lookin
dude i would but i had [ __ ] tits you
know so so anyway so uh you know it did
feel all the drugs and when I when I
drank alcohol when I smoke pot when I
did I didn't have tits dude I didn't
they went away they went away and as
soon as I was sober I had [ __ ] tits
so I mean that that that's the equation
right there yeah you know never be it
was just they went away and it was okay
and I could take a breath of fresh air
and be with my friends and not worry
about it you know if I got so good at
though if the wind was blowing a certain
way out I would arch my back it wasn't
it was you know and some of that still
if that fight is still there and mere
I'm like what and like I remember my ex
you know who was almost married to when
time she walked into the shower and I
covered my my chest up and shake you
don't have tits anymore i was just like
that I don't know why she it really hurt
you know I was like [ __ ] but I still
have that kind of like what are you
looking at but you know I'm a lot softer
now I'm lot more gentle so so I go to
rehab and this older like eight year old
just wizard was like we're all running
from something sweetheart and I was like
I don't know what you talk you know I
didn't see the way she was look at me I
was like I know you know she's like
whatever it is gonna kill you and she
just walked out and I was like my
[ __ ] kids so in the rehab which that
there's many funny stories about rehab
there was half prisoners there I was in
there with a hit man who was doing hits
from in there through through letters
great stories but but that's a way for
me to hide its tell those great stories
not finish with this story so just know
that there's a body of work that I
probably one day I hope to expose with
the world but um rehab was really fun I
really liked it it was great it was a
great experience a great time for me um
I've never heard anybody say that's
great anyone's I got through it i'm sure
i had a lot of ciders what was koed
there's a lot of girls aura it was fun
that there how long be night I was there
for like six months and so there's after
waffler the initial know what you liked
it but there's a bunch of girls there's
movie night hey we're going over here
and if you're good to get to go
starbucks it just stripped me down to
out get my hands on [ __ ] frappuccinos
like thank God you know cigarette of
Frappuccino I someone to bring in a
newspaper wedding get out they wouldn't
let me see anything for 60 days you know
it's just they threw me in our inner in
a room and gave me kool-aid and locked
the door and I just it was cold turkey
rieger I'm just telling you dude like I
withdrew off heroin um cold turkey just
getting locked in a room and I was like
there's a comic days we like crying
screaming sweat in a week yeah week and
it's bad for like couple months but I
there's a clock that looked like a cat
it was just like hey it was like one of
those things where I was like oh my god
but but uh so that the lady says that I
get to a computer in rehab and I just
google I am a man with tits send enter
it was like gynecomastia and I was like
okay okay cool mike weir do you know
what i mean like this has aim behind
there's so many other people and i read
really quickly and this is a community
computer there's like nine dudes in the
room and I was like okay delete one
dudes probably google and tips
so yeah yeah you don't ever be in there
is had something you know so so that I
was like okay there's a little tiny bit
of light the another thing so so I go
okay so I go I go home I get discharged
and I tell my parents i say i said i
need i need no help a lot a real estate
check from months and months and months
ago these deals take 18 months to close
this guy i called this guy to apologize
for my behavior for being such a wild
man you know and i was always cool with
them but I was like I owed him like 600
bucks like dude your checks and your
checks here like what he's like those
apartments like I got 10 grand waiting
the safe for you your mom told me not to
give it to you until you're out it was
like you know like I googled I have kids
again dr. Corbin Pines odd and he's like
I'm the tit doctor like uses older Jews
guy's hilarious it is like I'm the t he
had a really funny video and so III I
was like yo dr. Corbin I got cash and he
was like he was like let's get those
tits out so i went to the in beverly
hills on cannon street and the girl was
here for your nose that was really true
no but at that point I was like y'all
I'm here for my tears like chunk on the
goonies I'll tell ya I'm broken it I r
you know I'm not tall I'm kind of fat
whatever you know so like I just went in
and and so um also I'm i was getting
heroin from from those guys I I had from
the tanning but guys I had I want to get
into this too much but it does serve the
story I gotten in with these Hall this
really badass Hollywood connection I saw
him at the comedy store two months ago
and he was like papi you look good this
guy sells to everybody to every a-list
famous person their heroin all the guys
at he sells to everybody and I met him
on a fluke he thought it was funny and I
hadn't seen him in six months keep in
mind so I go into the surgery i don't
tell them that I'm an addict I don't
tell them all this [ __ ] so my mom and my
dad know their go k that I was like this
is what's been bothering me my whole
life alot like six months sober I go
when I get knocked out I wake up that's
right they got to put you out put me out
with heroin so right before I remember
lady went good night I was like yes dude
and I and I and I get my drugs losing my
dear log on and if
ever would have a surgery again I would
say hey I'm on my heroin addict right he
is there anything else and gave me cuz I
care now like before I was still like
didn't really know if I wanted to be
sober not so so i wake up from this
[ __ ] gnarly surgery and they cut my
you know i can show you guys after the
podcast but I mean you know I don't look
perfect but man in it I'm cool yeah I'm
[ __ ] cool dude all I wanted him to be
flat like I got my vision you know I was
like they were like teepees and I would
respect how could I you know I was about
to cut him out with the [ __ ] buck
knife you know I was like that's when
you're that suicidal you know um so so i
wake up from the surgery and I was like
and the guy wrote me a prescription gave
me Demerol which I'm opiate addict
didn't once again didn't share with
anybody so I wake up and I'm like party
time and so my mom and dad driving to my
dads and my moms like goodbye you know I
just sit on the couch my dad's in the
other room I take the whole bottle so
I've been knowing people like a lot of
them you know whether didn't give you
like a hundred but they know ten and
well yea though just bang you know and
i'm like yeah and I'm a real attic so
like when it hits me it's like it's like
in the movie beetlejuice when he's I say
it one more time like that's what it
feels like for me when I have relapse
like it like with six months three
months please God not again you know
it's been almost eight years but but I
don't want it anymore it's been lifted
but but it feels like Showtime let me
out you know it's like let me out of my
cage and so that happened so I called I
call my dealer and he's like papi what's
up and I was like dude he was like meet
me on on the street to street up in the
Hollywood Hills I got it they dad I have
to be right back my dad's like you can't
go anywhere my dad I'm [ __ ] you know
I was like I gotta go somewhere I gotta
go my dad's like what the [ __ ] I mean
I'm in a a male bra yeah i'm in a
compression garment like a bulletproof
vest / bra so i'm in this [ __ ] thing
and I'm foot the karate suit on haha I'm
two hours out of surgery and I'm up in
the Hollywood Hills and he this guy this
guy had a trunk full of a couple hundred
thousand dollars of the drug so he's got
you know the oxys were eighty dollars a
pill right God are they real all they
were young yeah so so so he had um he
had hundreds and hundreds if not
thousands of oxys which had 80 bucks a
pop you do the math so then he had
bricks of cocaine me this was and he
just flew under the radar little honda
it was the guy been doing it for her
there's their stories about him he was
dealing with a lot of people every
everybody that that you've listened to
music or watch TV he was the guy he was
the guy is the guy still and so um so I
go up there he goes uh I give him [ __ ]
carrie fisher's up there there's a story
about you know she's up there waiting
for her [ __ ] and uh I yeah I won't get
into that but you know he keep pops into
my car and I'm giving him [ __ ] about
being late he's like you that's princess
Leia's in front of you been waiting
longer than you papi and then all this
sudden he goes what what's up with you
because I was acting weird nose like ah
I just had surgery he was like so I'm
not gonna sell you the cocaine only the
oxy you know only that I was like he's
like I can't sell you cocaine after a
surgery gonna die and I was like please
please like he knows that yeah he's been
doing it for periodical guy yeah here's
an EpiPen yeah he's that he's that guy
he's that totally that guy and so and so
he sells me the the opiates and on my
please coke please Coakley so he finally
cells in the coke I take a bump in the
car my tits start shooting blood no way
they just start because it did something
it sped up my heart I'm I'm two hours
out of a major surgery yeah this is
crazy right he's seeing this and it my
tits are now oozing blood he goes papi
I'm outta here right [ __ ] Bobby I'm a
deer so this is right before the iphone
came out this is like 2007 you know I
think it may it came out I didn't have
the first one and I definitely have a
smartphone and go down to Astro burger I
get a back page I'm like I need to get a
hooker everybody's waiting for me at
home like I need to get a hooker
disregarding your bleeding tits every
dude I'm on I'm on one so so it's all
like I'm I'm oozing blood for my tits I
get a jacket I put it on I'm out of
surgery I'm all out of it and I start
taking all the drugs and and then I i'm
outside of astro burger i pick up a la
week with LA Express and I go to the
very back and there's just dominatrix
russian chick and I called her up and
she's like what do you want I was like I
was like I want I want wid character
already weird sex and she's like come
over
tampa street and in this russian chick
tamp out in the valley on the valley
baby I pass it all the time now I I did
I want did the road with Brody and we
passed HAMP and I was like there was you
know Here I am sober thank God so some
pass it so I go to her place and she
goes is it an apartment house it's a
house and she's probably a 6 foot 1
black-haired Russian [ __ ] who looked
like Robocop who was dressed like just
[ __ ] like a machine right it's all
leather Bubba boom very intimidating and
I go over and she goes okay take off her
take off his shirt and make sure you're
not a cop and I go no and then she was
like she was so used to that lifestyle
like she was like I was intimidated
because she was like take off your
[ __ ] shirt and I was like no and
she's like she started trippin cuz she
thought you know here's a guy he's
coming he won't take off his [ __ ]
shirt so I [ __ ] take it off and she
goes what the [ __ ] is that and I just
had surgery on my tits and I started
tearing up but she was like dude dude
that you should week nominees gate yeah
but but but it was so gnarly that you
saw the humanity seep in where she was
like I saw it in her eyes was like [ __ ]
dude hahahahaha you're the guy she's
still talking about obscure I want I
want to find out I think through phone
records i could find out i want to thank
her that was that was my last day of
using so so I'm over there and she goes
okay that's weird so she put a dog
collar on me and starts whipping me and
then takes this huge dildos like I'm
gonna put this in your ass I was like
[ __ ] some just out of my mind right
I'm out of my mind my tits are bleeding
it's coming through the jacket now she's
like that she's letting me keep on and I
go can I do cocaine shows no cocaine in
my house I go mistress she's you call me
mistress I said I'm permission to do
cocaine she goes she whipped my back
really hard i go ah it goes ok like she
could like almost sorry you know cuz
he's like dude she's not a monster oh
this is out there dude so so oh this is
out there I didn't know we were gonna go
this deep ok so no pun intended with
that dildo I guess it didn't I was too
tight she was telling me I was too like
scared like a cat it was just like fun
so what it wouldn't go in she might have
showed you some
see I think I think did you know what I
really think she showed you some mercy
so she sits there and I got it sir
please doing coach'll he's crying he's
doing cooking God she might have killed
you she probably do it so she goes I
mean so I said permission to do coke and
she said no so then I go I started
weeping and I ripped the the dog collar
off my neck and I said I just paid you
two hundred dollars for an hour of your
time can I please just do the rest of my
cocaine here I need to tell somebody
everything and she looked at me and she
goes okay and she went oh she went to
her room put on sweats so she was
dressed like Robocop came back and
jammies look like Sally Jessy Raphael
yeah sat at the edge of like this little
bed thing was like come in here and I
just did keys of coke while my tits bled
sobbing uncontrollably and told her
everything everything her mouth was
dropped that was like it was an all-boys
Catholic High School always had these
I'd she goes but they're gone now she
was like you know she was like cool and
I was I was breaking down sobbing
uncontrollably and I was like hugging
her and she was holding me and I was
doing the coke and I and I ended up
throwing some of the coke away and my
sister called me and she was like where
are you you come over to grandma's right
now all right and I go and I'm [ __ ] up
enough to be like I was the dude that
would do coke and go talk to cops i was
a weirdo officer as any problems out
here you know like I would do blow and
then go into the Lions Den that was my
like weird thing you know now I'm kind
of like like I don't wanna I don't want
to [ __ ] around too much i get i'm
sensitive but i would be blow and talk
to see HP in but what we got going on
here you know like I met a couple guys
in Rio that I had that same thing so so
I was like I'll be I grandma's no no
problem you know I'm i'll be there and
the girl goes you can't go to your
grandmother's house i was a guy gotta go
to my grandmother's house and so she
like washed kind of white me up and
stuff and wow the seat you up and
cleaned you up look at that and clean me
and clean me up um and and she goes okay
by you know good luck and so I went to
my grandma's house I walk in my sister's
eating a jalapeno and she does have a
jalapeno I don't know why this happened
it was really weird I just was [ __ ] up
enough to be like diversion grab grab
the jalapeno bid it my nose starts
cooking all the coke out right which is
I was already doing to start shootin
milk cheese or chata chata so so my mom
walks in and goes what the hell is
coming out of your nose and my sister
goes I just gave him I just gave him a
jalapeno look at my nose my sister's
nose starts running and my mom gives me
this look of like you [ __ ] like I know
you know what I mean it was like one of
those I was like are you gonna press
this I'm not gonna press this so then we
put your sister no no my I don't think
my sister did my mom did it so my mom
was stare to me here this guy was six
months he just had a surgery and so I I
hung out for a little bit I go to my
grandma's like what do you mean EST old
Italian grandmother did yes you know you
just you know that doing her own thing
you know and so until I go home and my
brothers at my dad and my brothers just
like [ __ ] this has gotta stop dude
you know and so and my dad's just quiet
and I go home and I go to go to sleep
after a few hours and I wake up and I
call my old sponsor in 12-step I know I
kept this off my we do an inventory
right where you tell everybody
everything I told basically I told this
dominatrix hooker everything I did a
quote-unquote fourth step with her and I
and I told her everything and so I
called Claudio my old swans I said
what's up and and I go I need to tell
you everything and so I went out by the
Burbank Airport where as when is this
the next day and so your are you high at
all still no but but i but i still had i
still had some um some [ __ ] left over
from the guy right yeah and I and I
think I did a little bit that day I did
a little bit that day and I go I have to
tell you everything he goes okay I took
off my shirt and he started laughing and
I was like do that hurts my feelings row
and he's like oh I'm sorry I just you're
wearing a bra dude like I you know I've
heard a lot i haven't heard this I was
like this is you know I'm this is always
bothered
me and this was always the thing that I
went to two other rehabs but I was like
I kept at arm's length and as soon as I
said that to that woman I felt like the
darkness lift from me and so I go what
do i do and he goes well we're just
gonna continue with the 12 steps you
just basically like it takes people
months it took me five years to get to
this point he goes just you know you
said everything he's like we'll just
continue with the thing and I was a
wooden I do now is if you have any more
drugs I said yeah home and he goes just
throw me on the toilet I was like well
it just a little bit the response or
ever yeah and and I go I go yeah i right
yeah I trust you thrown out you did some
today all right no big deal all thrown
down the room down the toilet in and I
and I remember being there's nothing
else to run from you know like there's
little things here and there and so I
went to a 12-step meeting and I randomly
saw a guy from Huntington Beach down
where I went to rehab and I looked at
him and I said I'm done he goes yeah
right dude because we're never done you
know and the guy still along stuff I
think today and I go I'm done dude I
just felt like the darkness left and
there's benim many other things other
addictions have come up another behavior
but that was that was my sobriety that
was May 31st 2008 and I have never drank
or used a drug since that every day's
that hooker may way after may thirty
first two thousand coming up it's coming
up that's that'll be eight years Anna
Morial day weekend you wouldn't blow it
out with the fuggin hooker great i don't
remember did I remember so then and that
was that you know and I just kind of
work towards it but that was that was
that I always want to call her and tell
her like that talk with her that was it
that was a changing point who knew
that's how it would came in but you know
and so on who knew that if that doctor
when you were 12 if you didn't know the
option I I'll bet money I mean maybe you
would have done coke and stuff like that
but I doubt you would it turn into a
heroin addict who knows you know who
knows who knows because I and why'd you
don't need to go down that path but
still you know it's like I did that that
was the road that I went down that was
the card I was given and that's what I
chose to do no rehab saved your life in
so many more ways because if you were an
addict and you got that $10,000 you
wouldn't had your sir no I would have
pissed it away on drums probably killed
yourself rehabs amazing if you're really
ready to go it doesn't do anything other
than give you some space to kind of make
a decision so when you're out there and
you're [ __ ] doing your thing you
don't really hot you're not you don't
have a decision but if you're like like
60 days pulled back and go do I want to
anyway this or not yeah that's all it is
and so rehabs it so it's a great tool
it's a great experience and I go back to
rehabs a lot now and um you know see
guys this is like it I could just look
at a guy a sec I don't know what it is
but you just you could just it's just
one or two so you know it's just one or
two things you know what is it what you
know and there's only so many weird
things that can happen mind mine's one
of the weirder was so I usually help a
lot of guys out by saying that because I
just when I could tell their second look
I had male breast surgery so what you
like oh ok well this this the Allen my
dad yeah yeah totally are like dude I
[ __ ] pseudo suck the dog's dick all
day or you know whatever but um but yeah
that so that's that's that story that's
the tit story so fighting on amex
Mexican talk show was that was that
during your drug days so that was during
the [ __ ] days I I like it you're the
only person I've ever met and probably
what I'm gonna say probably will ever
meet that has a [ __ ] era yeah in
their life as a book I yeah I like it
gotta be the only guy the [ __ ] air I
met him at a [ __ ] uh me my boss I
worked for a law firm during the day
assisting a buddy and I we have a
running joke he's like I met him at the
[ __ ] because I said that one day or
he said that one day we just kept
weeks's that's her for anything um so
okay so drink during that time period
add I had a cousin that was pretty a
pretty gangster pretty rough dude
started dating dating all hispanic girls
and you know were white and like sort of
living in like the rougher neighborhoods
and got in his own his own thing and he
kind of you know turn a little bit into
a cholo you know and like really just
kind of adopted the mexican them not not
just hispanic but like you know Southern
California Mexican kind of rough
lifestyle and I you know didn't hang out
them he was one of my best friends and
we lost touch in one day he calls me
while I'm in the karate suit starting
blow just chillin and uh and he goes
dude turn on channel 52 or whatever it
was and I was up and he goes do I just
went I just went to this [ __ ] this
show it's Mexican Jerry Springer turned
this [ __ ] on so I turned it on and it
was it's jose luis since and sudha it is
this crazy [ __ ] show and I'm like
watching and I'm and we're on the phone
and he's like dude I just went and was
on it and he goes and I go do there
knocking each other out because remember
Jerry Springer was pretty gnarly but
then they got they censored Wilco said
to come in d [ __ ] up this is dude
Mexicans don't sue so like and I say
this on stage I have this bit on sailor
jerry springer stops joseluis takes off
and so there's girls getting naked on
this thing people getting their teeth
knocked out so he goes you gotta go and
I said I dude he goes do you trust me
it's so fun there's no black people
there's no white people there's no it's
all Hispanic it's all gangsters and a
few grandmothers and just random people
this applies well same grandma's at your
UCB show' ok ya eatin spawn dulce
sweetbreads so so it's at Lieberman
broadcasting a burbank I'm living right
down there so so I roll over I get an
eight ball I roll over I do bunch of
heroin and I'm in a karate suit my
loucks and I just roll up your in the
karate suit and there you're there your
target well yes or no if I would have
went and just dress I keep in mind i had
tits and I was willing I was during that
time period of my life I hated myself so
much I was willing to go all in mm-hmm
all the tall of time so I was like yeah
because I'm gonna kill you oh yeah yeah
like Kevin Costner like Indian syllables
yeah I was like who's second Dances with
Wolves Candice I just listened to
Candace episode oh please take care of
my mules is he's getting shot that like
me and his comic Brett pants always talk
about that please take good care of my
mules as he's getting shot take good
care of my mules that stuck in my just
everything that hot baked yeah I'll
never forget that seat please take good
care of my mules can you imagine him
saying that and take good care of my
mules and he's getting arrowed that
[ __ ] with me so I so I roll up in my
whole thing is I got kicked out of the
catholic high school I went to an all
black high school I had orange hair
during the sublime era I did fine cuz i
was on meth and i just went straight
into it like what's up I wasn't tough
but I just was like what's up all the
ideas I just was crazy you know and so I
learned that you know you just you just
walk right to it you just walked right
into the [ __ ] and so if you're
willing to make that it's hesitation
that gets you you know you guys know
from stand-up I mean you can't be like
what's up [ __ ] you know into a rough
room and then people kind of trip so I
was wearing my karate
outfit coked-out it's all 18 street gang
members in the [ __ ] parking lot and I
roll up I'm like I'm like what's up like
what's up Karate Kid what are you here
to do and I'm like Crotty kids here to
[ __ ] fight dude and they were just
like Oh delay i was like you got karate
kids back and let me just stand up for
one second okay condition i'll free get
emotional oh so good so they go they go
what's up crónica isochronic you certify
they go all day I go you got karate kids
back and they said I say all you have to
do is throw one punch 18s got your back
its own stream yeah so you guys have 18
on their face and all these kind of
crazy right on their face so I and this
is shot in burbank and burbank see the
guy out of the big ears yeah if not now
if not then maybe now you know and so so
I role in you go through two metal
detectors and you sign your sign a
waiver that says if you get hurt you
know if you killed hurts tab because
there's it's [ __ ] fight night Google
jose luis sin censura fight night dude
so we walk in and I'm in sunglasses in a
karate outfit the only white dude in
there and they sit me right in for any
went solo your cousin Lee I should go
not like we should go just go but we're
he was crazy or both cottages yeah like
we kind of were like we got it you cuz
he was living thats it like he was doing
some weird [ __ ] he's doing his own thing
so yeah but it was yeah he knew i was
gonna be cockys alone and so I met him
at the [ __ ] so so I walk in and uh
and they sent me in front and my nose
starts just dripping coke they sit me in
front in the audience at any time you
just jump over and you start fist
fighting in the audience just there's
they make a ding ding and it's it's
brute I'll write in an interview show
that starts it's the arts fighting and
that it's good it starts with the
vignette [ __ ] in turn end yet yeah
he starts a little thing so the first
guy i see they pan the shot on me with
the opening shot i'm looking at myself
in like three TV monitors I'm coked out
and they start the establishing shot on
me they did the same thing to my cousin
he's gonna white boy in a wife beater
and he said Lusa my friend this guy
my friend he's Taylor catch him he's a
stand-up comedian he's in New York
things coming back to LA but he was on
the titles because we started going to
this thing and fighting a lot and he was
like he like ripped off a Raider a
Raiders shirt was like yeah I'd like he
was on the opening credits for like two
years so like he would always get
recognized people try to fight us on the
street le I don't know about him at
least me really yeah okay so sometimes
you think you're on the show like five
or six times just the audience about hop
in and just start swinging in it you
know God in the show when you say hopin
you mean hop up on the stage hop up on
the stand fistfight and [ __ ] fight
and whoever's who you is it dudes chicks
dude chicks every so you'll start
fighting chicks I did I never did but
yeah oh yeah i saw OC so so i roll up
but real quick how'd you do I got my ass
beat every time you never you know
better oh my mics out my my headphones
are out check check your thanks good
just your have okay so uh my mics
thought my headphones echo lift record
up up from underneath where you're at
yeah just get up on the table okay um so
so I roll out and um and I see the fur
they had they had women verse women some
like [ __ ] stories booing them and
the third I was like shocked South coked
out this girl punches the other girl all
the other girls teeth out and they just
go flying across the stage either good
yet dude google they had a too hot for
TV for jose luis sin censura it means
without sensors and the one girl ripped
the other girls top off so these hot
hispanic girls huge tits knocks the
other one's teeth out and they stop that
one they mop it up and they start the
next vignette and people i'm looking
back and people are just going [ __ ]
crazy right now I'm like here we go baby
you know like here we go and this is
during the real estate time to I think I
was doing real estate during this time
no restaurant i was doing restaurant
during this time i was we're gonna meet
piache and pasadena and so um the next
guy walks out and they said you know
they had some [ __ ] story so this
little like smaller Mexican guy walks
out and everybody starts booing him and
I boot him I was like boo and he just
looked over at me the sunglasses on in
sunglass I was like I'm not taking it
from this white boy I could hear him say
something like that and everybody
started booing me Jose Luis went up to
me walk right up dude so now I'm like
[ __ ] out of my mind he's like he's
saying you don't speak spanish and i
grabbed the microphone from him that i
said they actually started making
t-shirts with the song that I said no
hablo espanol and everybody goes boo and
I said yo hablo ingles that means I
don't speak Spanish I speak with my fist
dude and everybody just [ __ ] and I
turn around I'll just like yeah like I
started to give you 18 high fives and I
turn around and this guy just [ __ ]
clock why your glory it is like this is
real you know can you take out the
Catholic school like oh yeah we'll show
up with up this guy just little guy just
bangs me right so like I go down 18 just
pops me back up I hop over start
throwing some you know [ __ ] punches
and then the back wall just floods over
just stomps this guy the [ __ ] out dude
and then they're like yeah yeah karate
kid karate kid so I start doing the
crane thing everybody's going crazy so
like so they call me again like you want
to come back and so just like the
[ __ ] thing like I started hanging out
at jose luis sin censura right I'm
friends with him on facebook we talk you
know we're cool now I think he does
infomercials in Mexico some [ __ ] in in
uh he was a comeback stage you know and
I was like oh you I work with the
Jackass guys just like throw that out to
get into places so then I I never got
the footage i started i started going to
Lieberman broadcasting so much I was
like I need that footage and they're
like whoa okay we're gonna give it to
you agree and I freaked them out I can't
find that footage but then people with
people would see it people would see it
all the time because it would go it
would go to Brazil it was all over
Mexican television so you don't think
because I'm not watching her my friends
are not watching you don't realize it's
going out everywhere so it's going out
all over the Hispanic community which is
huge so I'd be like pumping my gas and
people like no hablo jingles bhutto and
just start trying to fight me it was
during the day when I was kind of doing
maintenance right so I was like I was
like a butcher ralphs awarded [ __ ] I was
like what's this about you know so crazy
I'll get on my mind to just do things in
a black I'd be like well I forget this
other because then when I started
getting Beetlejuice tout at night I
would be like I'll turn in this other
guy who deals and so I'm like one of
these guys [ __ ] doing so so I i was
working at me piache this italian
restaurant and down
town old town pasadena and these these
two Mexican brothers did not like media
there the bartender's they would never
put my I put my drink in and they would
[ __ ] would it make my drink and I'd
be like I was keyed up to so I was like
[ __ ] you dude i'll [ __ ] you guys up and
you know they're like oh you don't want
to mess with those two brothers they're
thugs and I was like [ __ ] them and so
there was like to stand off because i
put in a martini and like my tables not
getting her martini they like Stephen
and punch it in right you know I mean
they'd been there for like ten years and
so for whatever reason they just didn't
like my style and then one day dude I
punched my [ __ ] in and it just came up
instantly and I was like I was like what
I'm being trapped here cuz these guys a
bit addicted me for like the first month
though the month that I had worked there
and they're like crystal doubt kind of
like just dudes you didn't want to [ __ ]
with they had like like from a Quentin
Tarantino movie if someone were to be a
bartender like it was just weird they
just had that weird energy you know and
then there were being all nice to me now
my drinks are just coming up and they're
being shy around me and I and I was like
us I look in there like that i didn't
know i had no idea i'm like wouldn't
these guys are because I'd been lured by
this this guy that I that I that I beat
up in high school did a bunch of roids
came back with a whole army of people to
stomp me out and and I did I escaped
with my I got my ass beat a little bit
but I escaped but that had happened a
lot because be having the kids I had
such a big mouth that it did people just
knock I got in a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] so I was like I was like why these
guys being nice and then at the end of
the night because all my drinks were
just coming up or skipping the line at a
packed you know kind of high-end
restaurant um the guy was like so um can
I ask you a question I was like what
dude he was like you've--you you fight
on josé Luiz I was like yeah I was like
yeah go pong yeah it is yeah it is it's
Jerry Springer so I out you know I tell
this story a lot on stage but I'm like
you don't realize that like there's a
lot of Hispanic people out there in
Brazil's huge South America is huge in
the population here and whittier there
watching so just because we're not
watching on Comedy Central like people
see this so so he started giggling there
he told his brother he's like it to him
it's in like what's up when you win
you'll have lifting ghazals too dude I
was just golden with them and that that
would happen little times here and there
so that was when I was like oh [ __ ] this
this is pretty cool
I got addicted to that so I was I was
doing I was fighting on on Mexican TV
all my dad thought I was in a fight he
didn't really understand so I would come
home all knotted up my dad's I know
you're in a fight club he said some
funny guy i did a cut I the fight club
thing and during my high school days I
was like wow like whoa what yeah yeah
yeah you know it's think about your pair
just kind of leak out later yeah i
speared a whale you know you're like oh
so that you know that was that was I was
doing real estate at that time I was
doing I was doing us doing the
restaurants but I was I was just a now
all that all I wanted to do was stand up
comedy man so you know another another
podcast another time end up right after
I got sober met Sam Tripoli at a at a
sober meeting and I lied am I said I did
a bunch of data if he took me on the
road with him and tony hinchcliffe and
you know it's it's I'm so grateful for
me and Sam and he brought me right in
the comedy store and you know I'm I just
want to say how grateful I am i'm almost
eight you're sober I do stand-up five
six nights a week and I'm doing the
things that I talked about doing on
cocaine you know I was like oh I do
jujitsu and I'm gonna do stand up and
I'm gonna do that you know I have my
first sober relationship so you know
life's not perfect dude but like I'm I'm
doing the life that I told everybody I
was going to do when i was starting
lines i'm doing stand-up at the comedy
store man so it's it's a it's a good
life it's weird get my feelings hurt a
lot but uh but boy yeah I I hope there's
some more fun stuff in it and you know
it's uh it's kind of everybody says my
stories or gold that's kind of
harvesting these and I don't know how to
really present these to the world
podcast have been a great podcast and
stand-up have been a really um create
medium to do that and I'm writing some
scripts and you know what we'll see but
I mean there's I give you like five
percent of the stories there's a lot I
mean that dude oh I was in with like I
was [ __ ] around in Mexico with drugs
i mean there's there's a decade worth of
intravenous crazy behavior i'm sure
there is this yeah so I love the come
back and tell apart cup part two um
how's the jiu-jitsu it's or do I i I'm
training with uh with Roger Machado in
Beverly Hills Joey Diaz trains there and
I haven't gone in like a month and a
half I got to go back but it's it's
great man that's that's the only time
jujitsu and when I'm on stage doing
stand-up and actually in podcasting
that's when
that's when the craziness goes away yeah
that's cool yeah I'm not great i'm not
i'm a pretty decent stand up i'm getting
better like I'm I have a natural ability
I think that tells story but like I suck
at you I'm not dude I just get beat down
and it I love it I love it more than
stand up because i'm not there dude i
don't care i just have fun with it so i
have a blast in jiu-jitsu i'm not good
at it it is not what I'm supposed to be
doing and it's totally fun you still
wear the old gay you know what I gave
that away that's because it was such a
painful I got a new giddy like I threw
it in a Salvation Army that you know
those little bucket does little I yeah
donate the clothes I threw it in one day
I was like I can't I can't wear this
thing anymore so much pain yeah there's
a lot of history and Nike not lot not
one punch thrown it no just just a lot
of weird stuff man well thank you so
much for coming on this was eye-opening
and lightning and rewarding your [ __ ]
clean and sober so that's great man
thanks um want you one more time to
everybody what you want them know about
your social media your podcast great yet
podcast is on all things comedy monday
three o'clock it's sam Tripoli and I
it's called international bad boys it's
a storytelling podcast it's really fun
love doing it so follow us on social
media you know just Google international
bad boys also my twitter is at Steven
Randolph that's st e ven R a n D olph to
the number to Steven Randolph to it's
also Steven Randolph to on Instagram and
Steven Randolph on facebook add me on
Facebook and I'll talk to anybody just
just shoot the [ __ ] and let's have some
fun and also I love doing this too if
you've heard the podcast if you had a
good time i'm at i work the door at the
comedy store sometimes outside it gets
boring come up and say you heard me on
crab feast man i like the no number i
always do that with our podcast and a
lot of people it's surprising who's
watching so if you heard me on crab
feast let me know you heard me on crab
feast when I'm at The Comedy Store I
work the door so I'm pretty friendly and
talk to anybody right on right man as
always Jay Larson calm be calm Jay
Larson comedy one on Instagram Twitter
and Pinterest Ryan Sickler on all social
media Ryan Sickler calm will talk to you
next Tuesday